جماهير بلده بيتمر شمال الخليل تشيع في
هذه اللحظات جثمان الشهيد عزيز خليل الذي
ارتقى يوم امس في مواجهات اندلعت ما بين
الشبان وقوات الاحتلال في منطقه الظهر
ببلده بيتمر شمال الخليل قوات الاحتلال
اطلقت الرصاص الحي باتجاه الشبان اصابت
شبين واحد منهم الشهيد خليل الذي اصيب
بالرصاص الحي في منطقه البطن وخرجت من
منطقه الفخذ نقل مباشره الى المستشفى
الاهلي في مدينه الخليل وهناك بعد نصف
ساعه من وصوله اعلن الطاقم الطبي عن
استشهاده بعد فشل جهوده في انقاذ حياته
بارتقاء الشهيد عزيز خليل نتحدث عن الشهيد
الخامس في هذه البلده منذ السابع من
اكتوبر فقط ارتقى خمس شهداء في هذه البلده
التي تقع الى الشمال من مدينه الخليل وكما
تشاهدون في هذه الصوره هذه الجماهير التي
شارك في هذه اللحظات في تشييع جثمان
الشهيد عزيز خليل من بلده بيتمر الى
الشمال من مدينه الخليل وهذه الحشود التي
تظهر في هذه الصوره والتي تشارك كما ذكرنا
في تشييع جثمان الشهيد عزيز خليل منتصر
نصارى الجزيره بلده بتمر شمال الخليل